welcome back to CBS mornings we've got
an update on a CBS News investigation
into toxic water at a Marine Corps Base
in North Carolina so we've been
following this story for more than a
decade now and a new law may allow as
many as a million people mostly Marines
and their families to sue the government
over contaminated water at Camp Lejeune
now the law is a major change for
veterans and others who say that they
suffered illnesses as a result of their
service at the base senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is at
the Pentagon with more on the story
Catherine good morning to you good
morning Gail veterans told us that suing
the government is about acknowledging
they were harmed by toxic water and
getting accountability from the Navy and
Marine Corps
how old are you in this picture I was
19. Bruno teshera was already a marine
did you spend a lot of time working with
the water at Camp Lejeune every day
teshura worked in the mess hall at the
coastal North Carolina base for three
months in 1986. you were exposed to
potentially toxic steam how many hours
every day two or three hours every meal
maybe maybe eight nine hours every day
every day
the U.S government acknowledges that
from 1953 to 1987 nearly a million
veterans and civilians were potentially
exposed to dangerous chemicals in the
Camp Lejeune water in some areas levels
were 400 times with safety standards
allow nobody told us anything about
chemicals but we did notice that the
water did have a a strange taste and
smell you guys want kettle corn the
father of two says he's not a smoker or
a drinker after severe stroke in 2015
his doctor blamed the toxic water did
you feel a sense of betrayal yes we were
serving as Marines we were taking care
of others but we expected our own people
take care of us the Department of
Veterans Affairs internal Watchdog found
a third of recent disability claims for
Camp Lejeune veterans were mishandled or
wrongly denied the V8 turned down
teshira's disability claim saying it did
not find he had maximum exposure they
hired an expert so-called expert that
reviewed my medical files never spoke to
me never examined me why did you get
involved in Bruno's case this one really
breaks your heart Senator Corey Booker
from tashira's home state New Jersey
says veterans deserve more in many ways
they've been poisoned as a result of
their service and yet they were denied
this is what we called Baby Heaven A CBS
News investigation revealed still bursts
rare childhood Cancers and other
illnesses among Camp Lejeune veterans
did the CBS investigations have impact
God yes you expanded people's empathy
and helped to add fuel to the demand
that Congress do something about these
injustices in August the Camp Lejeune
Justice Act was folded into new
legislation that expands VA coverage for
toxic exposure illnesses and opens the
courthouse doors for Camp Lejeune
families why are you suing the
government for damages I mean what they
caused we were innocent we didn't know
anything about this so what do you say
to critics who say this is a money grab
well I'll let them be exposed to toxic
water for about three months and then
let them get back to me that's honorable
discharge like many veterans interviewed
for the CBS investigation teshira had no
hesitation about his service I love
being in the Marines I would do it all
over again cutting out capitalizuno I
wouldn't set footnot base
the Camp Lejeune water claims are
shaping up to be one of the largest mass
litigations in U.S history the Navy told
us that 14 000 claims have already been
filed citing the ongoing litigation the
Navy is not commenting on the size of
potential Awards flat
Catherine I'm struck by Senator Booker's
words poisoned as a result of their
service thank you for your report we
appreciate welcome